okay I set it up and I had to restart at
Hayes he's trying to get you on inside
and I [ __ ] it up he's trying to get
you on Instagram on your way what time
did you get in there we tweet we didn't
know you were here earlier it had to
come in okay that's very nice Jim would
never have um I don't know I didn't see
it you mean not the movie or the comic
like originally I think it was last year
yeah yeah did you like it
I watched it all the time yeah it's a
good one
do you like her better than Lynda Carter
gal gadot gal gadot you know put on some
glasses she has a looker that gal gadot
but does she have breasts like Lynda
Carter Lynda Carter very heavy breasts
no gal gadot has more of an athletic
build she does yeah he's very evenly
proportioned yeah are you a big
superhero guy I don't I've never watched
the Supergirl isn't that just the TV
show not a film no a superhero movie
like or do you like superhero movie
Supergirl I never saw either super
superhero movies like give a [ __ ]
Thor no yeah I was just watching Doctor
Strange on the plane from San Diego to
LA JFK is it good movie over and over
again you catch something you didn't
catch the first time was it there's
something we were talking about the
Avengers the last you saw I'm sure you
saw the last Avengers movies on show
that's okay I mean you've you've you've
earned your hearing your hearing
problems you've seen I'm sure you've
seen a newest Avengers movie right with
the yes you know turning everybody into
dust and whatnot wasn't it frustrating
infinite infinity war that's it that's
it wasn't it frustrating that you go
through the whole movie it's two and a
half hours and you just get to the part
where it's like okay now we're getting
somewhere
and that's the end of the movie didn't
they all die then yeah I didn't
[Laughter]
yeah he does yeah but you kind of know
some of them are gonna come back like it
like it's so it's such a part one that
for me I was like I'm ready for part two
now you're gonna make me wait a year for
this yeah well that's what they do they
do
I I've never seen it I don't I don't
really like superhero movies I just
don't enjoy them don't let ace hear you
say that aren't you a kiss fan yes but
that's where it begins and ends with me
okay it's kiss you're the only superhero
is I like yeah that's the issue that Jim
watches these superhero movies and he
goes they're not as cool whose kiss or
who cares how man was Peter that they
dubbed over his didn't they double for
his voice and kiss Pete's The Phantom of
the park they dubbed over it yes what
was it because he was a bad actor or did
he say something didn't like well acting
had nothing to do with it it was just
the quality of his voice
maybe his Brooklyn accent I thought was
a little too much I mean I have the
Bronx accent but it's getting better
because I've been living in California
for ten years
did he tell him they were gonna do that
or no no they blindsided I know what
that's like because you know way back
one when I was working with kiss you
know they changed one or two solos of
mine and had another guitar player come
in what was it was it for Detroit Rock
City today what do they do that on what
songs I'm trying to think I'm trying to
forget about it did you know it like as
soon as you hear someone like that do
you know that's not me playing oh I know
immediately but you know if if they were
gentlemen they would have informed me
prior to me hearing the final version
what was their reasoning for it but did
they tell you a reason that was
acceptable I think when they rerelease
dynasty they actually put in the old so
long there was nothing wrong that maybe
they felt it could have been better I
don't know I think they did it to punish
me because I was always late did you
stop being late after that no I see oh
now why you were late you dipped a few
back tonight before well you know some
days get hard getting out of bed yeah
did they
complain when you were late I just went
to Australia with Jim and I made sure I
was on time for everything was the
impressed that you would like got your
[ __ ] together a little bit at this stage
in your life at 12 years sober you at
home you would hope I'm going to be on
time I can read a clock do you guys get
along now yeah we were reminiscing on
the tour and you know he was kidding
around my wife Rachel and we had we had
a hell of a time you know no negative
vibes right positive I opened for him
then he did an hour and a half and I had
to sit around backstage because he
wanted me to come on and do rock and
roll night and deuce with him uncle so I
didn't want to pass up that opportunity
so I just hung out in the green room or
the Blue Room or the pink room whatever
color Jim I noticed the way you said oh
cool as a fan you would have been okay
seeing that I would have been very very
happy you would have to have seen them
playing deuce and rock n roll night
together yeah yeah now what's the
confrontation like when you realize that
your guitar solo has been replaced by
some other guy would that mean every
psyche in the seventies yeah it's such a
dead issue at this juncture but do you
go to them and go like what the [ __ ] are
you guys doing well you know I I
complained about it you know after the
fact but you know they were like what do
you want to do well yeah how can I
complain when I'm late and I'm loaded
yeah they're kind of right you know at
this point in my life you know twelve
years sober I have no tolerance for
drunk people really you know no
tolerance so you can't sit there and be
like that was me once I get it you know
they don't know what they're doing I
can't handle it well you haven't when
the drunk guy comes up to you for a
cipher get started playing do they give
you that when they start telling you how
much you meant to them as when they were
kids growing up and it's just a drunken
mess well as long as they can put a
sentence together
you know I give a response but if it's
one of those slurred blurred can't do it
you can smell it on them
yes smell
breath where they're sweating it out
yeah like when I'm doing VIPs backstage
when I'm on the road you know sometimes
the breath coming off some of these guys
you know try to get them try to move
them out as fast as we can yeah have you
had guys cry when they meet you have you
had guys cry when they meet you I've had
guys cry I've had guys kiss me oh I'm it
was really strange some guy goes can I
hug you and I said okay I guess next
again always kiss him on the lips all
right I've got a few cheek kisses to
have you yeah you get oh yeah I don't
like your surprise on that - that kiss
you he couldn't even believe there were
meet and greets for you know when
they're usually not sold out ace if you
want to come I would say I've had one
guy cry when he met me just once it was
outside a club and it was very odd yeah
you know how do you handle it
um I just try to talk to him I'm like
ooh this is the same type of mentality
go pull out a pistol it's okay but I
gotta get out of here I gotta get out of
here right now yeah it's a little
frightening so how are you in Australia
we were there for about five days we did
four shows and then gene was supposed to
the subsequent and they come to Japan
with me and then he decided to cancel oh
so I took his his backup band and we I
did eight shows in Japan and that was
very successful wait he was gonna go
with you went on his tour and then he
cancelled going on yours what was
supposed to be his shows in Japan no
actually he was just doing one vault
experience in Tokyo and and somehow it
didn't pan out or something was pressing
at home I never got an answer why but
those were those experiences when you
bought the bait remember the big box
yeah of course he was in a boat though
so he's going around the safe delivery
yeah there's a giant safe
I use mine as a coffee please give you a
discount
they gave it okay that's very nice very
nice but so he flaked on Japan and you
went over with his band yeah you know we
did eight shows and had a great time and
then I decided you know maybe it's time
to use
these guys you know in lieu of my old
band how does your old band feel about
that they're a little upset what you
just dumped them for James band now is
it are these guys better or they just
newer they're better in the sense that
they're more hungry everyone sings lead
they really nail all the parts musically
and they pick up the phone wait you guys
don't pick up when you call a lot of
times no but this would be like if if
Jim if you and I went in like we're
guests on Jason Alice's radio show and
then we came back with his staff and
just told our guys to beat it played it
we got a whole new staff the entire I've
never heard of the entire band being
replaced with jeans band especially
because you go over there and they're
like okay he's going over there with
jeans band and then you come back and
they're just all replaced I mean it
wasn't a big deal with Chris wise
because he's been working with the
Hollywood vampires playing bass mm-hmm
and he's also been doing some solo shows
with Joe Perry I mean you know he's one
of the most sought out bass players in
Los Angeles so he was pretty cool about
it my drummer Scott Cogan he didn't take
it too well
telling well how did you tell him I told
him I was moving on with jeans cover
band and I'm not gonna need you anymore
at this juncture and you know ace come
on what are you talking about because
I'm his rap star we want then he's
hitting me up for money and and but the
hardest thing for me was was calling
Richie Scarlett because his wife you
know just passed away and I knew she was
you know didn't have very much time to
live because she had Lou Gehrig's
disease and there's no cure so I was
procrastinating for a week not to call
him finally I got enough guts up the
column and you know he was like
so drain you know because you've been at
the hospital every day so on and so
forth but you know after I told them he
just couldn't couldn't grasp it with
everything else go surrounding his you
know what he was going through so he
pretty much hung up on me and then but
I've known Richie the longest 35 years
mm-hmm so I waited a to go by and I
called them back one evening a couple of
days ago and we made up he apologized
hanging up on me we discussed and
reminisce about old times he reminded me
that I dated his wife before he'd you
didn't remember well I kind of you know
but not really she was a wonderful woman
and really enjoyed life and her and
Richie had so much fun together and I've
met so many people to make him look
silly short you know he decided a so
whatever is best for you why won't you
want you to go ahead and do it you know
and then I decided to pay for after
funeral but your drummer still pissed
yeah I'm actually going up to speak at
the funeral today oh wow you know it's
between four and eight o'clock so I'm
gonna start heading up from the city of
before so there was no way you could
have just kept a one or two of those
guys in the band and then used a couple
of people from genes band it was kind of
all of these guys or all of these guys
well these guys from Nashville they were
unit you know it's like all or nothing
and they're terrific you know I mean I
remembered I remember doing mm man in
Tokyo and I you know with my old bang I
mean they were great live and great
musicians in their own right but the
vocals weren't always there because
they're not all lead singers well you
know this new band is all lead singers
so all of a sudden I'm playing mm man
and when the band kicks in
I'm hearing the three-part harmony that
I haven't heard since I was with kiss
because the year ban wouldn't how many
people would chime in in your band as
opposed to three well it just wasn't
there you know you know Chris Weis
I love him he's one of the greatest bass
players in the world but he's really not
a lead singer
Scottie's they only really lead singer
the drummer
yeah and he's distilling a band the
drummer's not that happy was very
displeased
he's joy they haven't made it he hasn't
made up with the drum are you good at
firing people right it's hard to do no
really hates it that old drummer he
really doesn't like it at all it's it's
I know I don't actually like being a
boss I remember the days I was in kiss
where I didn't have to get involved with
the business that off that was Jean and
Paul right there were more of that enjoy
business orientated with me and Peter
with more part party orientated and I
didn't really have to you know I didn't
fire anybody I don't think it's the
first time in your life you had to fire
people mm-hmm no well a little earlier
on in my career just Oh solo band stuff
I had a bass player uh back in the
eighties who had sex with my wife
Wow I think it was time for him to go
home as you fire the wife too
yeah did you get divorced did you stay
with her I'm with Rachel now I'll see
you guys how did you find out and was it
while you were still married
mm I don't remember exactly you told me
if somebody may have tattled on him in
the band or I've jennette admitted it
whatever oh wow
so you called him did he deny it at
first I just said you take hit the road
brother you didn't want to hear his
story I didn't want to talk about it I
didn't want to rehash it I just you know
it's over do you talk to Jeanette about
it yeah like why Jess I mean she was you
know she was upset and sorry but you
know I mean I'm not perfect you know
I've had numerous affairs no you've
strayed occasionally yeah
have you ever dated a woman and not
remember dating or you know it's the
weirdest thing that happens to me at
parties what's that girls come up to me
and they're a little older and they go
hi remember me because I can't remember
I was loaded you don't want to be
wondering the whole conversation that I
[ __ ] it right so when people ask you
like ace how many women have you been
with you go how would I possibly know
the answer to that question
well nowhere near the amount jeans been
with his jeans number true or does he
does he a disease I had this no it's
true is there I mean you know we had a
place called the chicken coop which was
nickname
it was just the hospitality suite we
have girls waiting for us mm-hmm you
know I go in there have you know have a
few orders and then watch some girl that
I connected with I take her back to my
room but you know one girl right gene
would go grab a girl spend an hour in
his room go back to the hospitality
suite for seconds and thirds don't be
there that's the amazing part they'd
still be at the hospitality suite oh
yeah yeah hoping really hoping Wow
I'll come in and the second and third
place is still good and then eventually
the roadies would end up with the
stragglers you know that are just
hanging on so it was this now was that
was this room would you guys go in right
after the show when you were all sweaty
with your shallow oh we would shoot back
to our rooms jump in the shower
put you know get dressed nice with a
jacket or a suit even so take the makeup
off oh yeah
but this was in the days where you guys
were very protective about the makeup
but I guess it was not no cellphone
nobody had cameras and stuff like no
cellphones right so you can get overs
taking pictures so did people but did
the girls all like know for sure that
you were who you said you were cuz
nobody knew what you look like yeah I
mean you know I had the same hair the
same bill now
you ever go into these rooms and like
there'd be guys hanging out in there
that were just like fans of yours going
like what the I know the bodyguards were
like guys there's all girls I'll say
during during the course of the show
we'd point that girls in the audience to
our bodyguards and they would write them
back to the hospitality you made sure
that none of the girls had boyfriends
though right
oh I didn't care I just didn't want them
back there so so a boy a guy could
theoretically take his girlfriend to a
kiss show and if she got the finger
point of doom how is it for him sorry
bud did anybody strike out in the
hospitality suite Danny you guys and not
get laid oh no like was ever a time that
Peter went in there we're Paula and they
nobody wanted to [ __ ] yeah I'm here for
Paul yeah they know why would they were
there they know you knows that's why I
don't understand the whole bit Cosby
thing you know I mean if a girl's in a
celebrity's um hotel yeah hotel room
what are they expect gonna happen why I
guess they're expecting to at least
remain conscious
yeah they PI don't expect a drugged yeah
like I doubt they probably don't think
that the that Cosby's gonna knock them
unconscious and then have sex with them
while they're unconscious yeah that was
a big issue I never did that and that's
good to hear because right we are one of
the four guys in kiss you probably don't
have to do a lot of forceful things too
late no but I got a kick out of the
girls in the South because sometimes
they they find out my room and I hear
we're not gonna do and they go I
[Laughter]
pronounce ace ice so would you ever say
you're sitting there you've already been
in the hospitality room you think the
evening is over right you're ready to go
to bed yeah like four o'clock in the
morning and then there'd be a knock on
the door and would you respond to those
knocks and be like all right one more
all right usually I wouldn't respond but
I come to the
and then I heard some girls say ice
right right so Jean would go back in
there for seconds and thirds in the
hospitality room absolutely
Wow I respect that Wow how about Paul
Paul pretty much was more like me you
know he was happy with one girl and
Peter yeah I think you know we were all
happy too baby just one pretty girl you
know Jean know what she didn't drink a
lot right hinting at all Brian didn't
drink at all so he would I mean he was
not inebriated so he needed the sex to
just you know be his entertainment for
the whole evening affair with women
since he was young now will you all
hopefully all were you all wearing
condoms I hate them so you were fairly
promiscuous raw doggin raw doggin let me
tell you what happened in the 70s was
wonderful right when the 80s certain
aids hit I slowed down a lot you don't
want them to call you space AIDS but you
weren't wearing condoms in the seventies
a lot of times just it takes track it's
like putting a condom on your tongue and
trying to tongue kiss with a girl give
me a break yeah yeah did you ever did
you ever contract in a sexually
transmitted infection I mean yeah
they're treatable it's not a big deal
just out of curiosity I mean I've caught
a couple over the years but only once or
twice maybe three times
pretty good right you got a shot of
penicillin but you know what once that
happened you know we still go can get
shots of penicillin every month just to
prevent it from you know grabbing ahold
of you and crabs I read some of what you
guys would get crabs and we got crabs
all the time and unfortunately in the
beginning
their outfits in one crate oh but that
Krabs would go from one outfit to the
other and next thing you know I wake up
and I'm scratched and I'm going what the
hell is going on so you'd be on stage
and you'd have crabs in your [ __ ]
gear yeah but the next day we go and get
that lotion you put on no problemo
the medicated lotion who's that I don't
know Steve Mary who's that who's that
Jim you don't know who that is humble
pie humble pie I did not recognize him
yeah that's awesome
where was it get back at a New York
to do I'm gonna be walking people down
the aisle
what you mean did you hear about that I
did not oh okay well I'm doing a QA and
assigning at the kiss mini-golf at the
Rio Hotel in Vegas and and then the
organizer called me up a couple of weeks
back and he goes would you like to be
the best man at somebody's wedding and
walk the globe and you're giving away
the bride oh my god yeah I said how much
was a big number I said okay how long
it'll take you guys 15 20 minutes I go
that works for me I imagine a a lot to
get a CA that'll walk your bride down
the aisle I would imagine but it would
be worth it wouldn't it yeah do you guys
do you get like weird offers like that
to do [ __ ] that has nothing to do with
kiss like it's because you already kiss
well because your age but other stuff to
do
strange strange things have happened but
I'd rather not go into them right well I
imagine a lot of guys ask you if you
wanna have sex with their wives even
even I've gotten that and if I get that
I know you know asked me to have sex
with his wife I wish it was judge Jim
Norton singer Sebastian Bach is that
right his current life no his old one
did you know why not because I love sir
but he asked you to have sex with his
wife well you know I I mentioned to him
I said I think your wife's beautiful and
he goes you can have her if you want to
go no I got plenty of women talk about
it but you know that's very good of some
guy yeah he's really gentle my
gentlemanly of him and but I didn't take
it up on him because I didn't wanna
gentlemanly of both of you question yeah
well your good guy yeah
now line I know I knew him before he was
in Skid Row [ __ ] I'm up I met him up in
Canada he was only 19 or something and
then lo and behold two or three as lady
was the lead singer in Skid Row and I
got a call from Eddie trunk you gotta
see this band delete sing is amazing I
go what's his name Sebastian Bach I go I
know yeah and then go forward even more
you were turning down having sex with
his wife it only happened once and you
know it you know he almost said it
jokingly but but it wasn't it could
happen well not if he wanted to happen
if I if I press the is embarrassing if
he was joking and you took him up Pollak
all right I'll [ __ ] and like I'm
kidding dude yeah except you said you
kiss me and he'd be like uh-huh okay all
right now do you did you know the guy
you're sitting next to Jim Norton one of
the most fascinating things we're
talking about crabs and one of the most
fascinating things that I find about Jim
I've never met a guy and you tell me if
this has ever happened to you would you
forget about Jim has this ever happened
to you where you'll have intercourse
with a woman she'll give you crabs
you'll use the lotion you'll fix
everything and seven days later you
going back and have sex with the same
woman you get crabs again does that ever
happen no not as I wouldn't have I
wouldn't go for the second time I went
back in double-dipped and I wanted to
confirm that she gave me crabs and as
soon as we [ __ ] I pull all those
little Joker's out I'm like yep it was
her I guess she was and I think I have a
lot of choices about a
and would you because would you use that
rid medication and you gotta calm the
eggs a humorous I think I was called
rude we don't want to plug any products
do we not paid would you endorse an anti
crab medication if the money was right
okay there's probably several out there
but yeah I haven't even heard about
anybody getting cribs a long time
because everybody shares that I shaved
my pubes I don't have pubes I don't
think every I don't think there's many
guys shave as you think they do Jim and
you know you don't hear much about AIDS
I remember in the 80s it was like you
know people would dropping like flies
yeah but you know obviously the
pharmaceutical companies have come you
know helped out and in that end yeah
they have way now more if you get it
it's not necessarily a death sentence
you can kind of you know you can get big
magic Johnson has been taking that
cocktail since what 1992 I have yes I
had a tour manager who passed away from
AIDS Wow
but you know he pitched for the other
team and you know it's Russian roulette
back then oh yeah behaving a little
rusty a little risky yeah yeah that's a
big big chance your ace is a newer I
don't like it's a album anymore I guess
it's a new CD it's just called spaceman
no it's an album we just shipped 8,000
units of vinyl oh it is alright she's
just weird to say album CD doesn't make
you sound any more relevant no did I say
CD said I don't like to say album
anymore obviously CD just say record
because I thought was my first thing but
that even sounds older than album you
could say album our ace has a new record
called spaceman gene gene considered now
this disc vague there's a new musical
collection being released by ASA
and gene is on this do all you guys get
along now or is there any like just
Peter still talk to everybody does
anybody not talk everybody all right I
still want a picture with all for you
together and I've had enough of this
because I find it amazing how the media
blows right these negative things out of
proportion you know you know when I call
Paul you know 18 months ago or two years
ago you know to sing on fire and water
it was just like I had spoken to him you
know 10 years ago it didn't matter you
know time doesn't really affect the fact
that the four
had this you know collective thought to
do this amazing group and design the
makeup and I mean look it's just gone on
forever but I called Paul and I said hey
I'm doing this album of covers would you
like to sing one of them and he
originally said my generation and I said
you know I love that song but I don't
think it should be touched but I knew he
was a big Paul Rodgers fan so the next
day I called them you know we was not
both snowballing and I said what about
fire and water spitballing case you were
not snowballing that's my favorite kiss
story ever snowball that's a great story
it's snowballing snowball so you're
spitballing and you came up with a Paul
Rogers song spitballing is the snowball
sounds great yeah yeah to me small
snowballing sounds better I'll accept
yeah bu so you and Paul were snowballing
I mean you came out and you came up with
this song what's a lot what's the
longest any of you guys have gone
without talking what was like was it ten
years or five years I don't think so I
you know if I if I didn't talk to Paul
for 10 years and called them up you just
say is what's happening you know it's
like that same with Jean Sammet Peter
what are the odds that the four of you
end up together in a room that's the
question because Jim had the opportunity
and do what whatever it is take a photo
with Jim Norton that's all that really
is all no ball if you want
I think it's conceivably possible okay
that's better news than you've heard in
the past it is yeah because Tom Morello
said you guys will never be in the same
room again so I was gonna go to the Rock
and Roll Hall of Fame induction just to
get a photo with all four of you guys
we're all together you were yeah but I
didn't do excited to gig and I couldn't
cancel the gig which was stupid up any
regrets he talked about all the time he
regrets it ever since because he doesn't
have a photo with all four of you guys
together and Norton is the biggest kiss
fan in the world
so you know to hear to hear you say it's
conceivably possible that's huge that's
a step in the right you know for the
last six months of last year
you know whenever Paul's been asked I
ever gonna play with ace again he said
absolutely not you know the past is the
best but you know now we're in the
future I think we asked him that and he
said the same thing no yeah yeah you may
have but you know like last week he
somebody asked him if I was gonna be
involved with the end of the road tour
and you said I wouldn't rule it out
hey at the end of the road oh they're
gonna be there what does that mean I
wouldn't rule it out yeah that's not
saying no that's right well and now
would Peter be involved with that can he
still play Peter can still play I don't
believe he could do a two-hour show but
Peter could definitely come out at the
end and do Beth and black diamond and
one or two others would he do that I
mean Bill Ward was insulted I think
Simon suggested that he was asked to do
it and he didn't do it I think it'd be
really silly you know he's like 72 now
and it would be his last hurrah
yeah that's one of those opportunities
you can't you shouldn't say no to some
people do cuz a prize crazy about the
whole concept of doing I did a reunion
to it 15 years ago but you know he's got
doing I would I would not turn it down
because of my fans I know the fans were
one or more than anything yeah and those
are the people that put us up on a
pedestal and they're the ones that
bought us our beautiful homes and cars
and you name it and you know gave you
crabs and all that other stuff just a
couple so now that you're married
obviously you're happily married you
miss that all that crazy life no I've
done it all you know I have no regrets
you know my sponsor naa he said to me
you shouldn't have regrets about
anything you've been through even if
they were major mistakes because you had
to get through those to get to where you
are today
you know you had to get certain stupid
things out of your system that you did
so I don't really regret anything I did
I don't regret quitting the band twice
you know because I I needed to get away
I needed to get my head school
on straight and you know Here I am today
in my career's going on there's an
upward so I was watching old footage
there's an old Detroit Rock City for
like 76 a live version that was from
Japan and I'm watching it and they're
all just sitting there nobody and that
was weren't they no - audience yeah yeah
they were like at that point they were
all very polite they would literally
just sit there and applaud in between
your songs that's the way they used to
be I mean I just played Tokyo and they
were up on their feet going crazy that's
off-putting that wasn't it when you're
playing when you're [ __ ] you play yes
I was before Tokyo was westernized yeah
yeah is it tough though to be up there
and be like are we bombing right now
like are they not feeling these songs
are you prepared enough to go like okay
they're gonna just sit there this is
just what they do there we didn't take
it as an insult initially because we
were told that's just the way their
audience is you know I mean I'm sure a
lot of the girls got wet in the pants
right right you probably know that
because I'm sure you've been in Tokyo
there was a hospitality room there was a
chicken coop actually what Sam why every
time I've been there I've either been
with my wife or a girlfriend so you know
you've never had sex with a Japanese
girl in Japan but you've had sex with
Japanese women in America you have but
you would always bring somebody isn't
that kind of bad move to bring somebody
on the road uh yes no don't bands have
rules about that no wives sick depends
your mindset and you know so a lot of
bands have their own bus and take their
family on the road every guy in the band
has a his own bus you know it depends
who you are and how much money you have
and and you know what you can afford
how are you guys doing that at the end
when you were doing the reunion tour
were you doing everyone had their own
bus no we had jet we had a g3 seated
like 20 people yeah but I had a girl
friend with me on on the tour for the
first nine months and then what happened
she had to go to rehab
[Laughter]
yoga teacher and she's sober and has a
beautiful daughter and but the tourists
entered a rehab Wow
she had she had the problem before she
got on the tour so it just was it
exasperated it was accelerated point
where like one especially when you guys
are younger there's four of you you all
have different women all the time we are
what we're a girls acting crazy or being
[ __ ] up backstage or on the plane and
just like oh he's got a nut with him it
happens being embarrassed by it well I'm
not none of the girls I was ever with
lost that in front of the band you know
they knew that place so that's good
if gal I've got wonderful if gal gadot
comes to you now
and she's wearing the Wonder Woman
outfit and everything and she says she's
got this own as with this fantasy get in
trouble with Rachel now she's not
listening she knows her thing she's yeah
she's busy doing a hundred someone will
hit us and tell us but that would be a
difficult one for you to be like you
know what I'm in a monogamous
relationship right now I mean it might
the old days might have to come out at
that point yes I plead the fifth she
said this how about if she said look I
heard that you're a fan of my film I
appreciate that I'm a big kiss fan I'd
like you to hold my breasts just hold
them just hold let's just say if you
were a single man okay you and you had
the opportunity to be with gal gadot
sexually do you think you'd wear
protection
[Laughter]
pretty clean lady secret once you use
the finger and then you hug and kiss you
take a sniff and yeah you know you can
always smell it on them if it stinks
yeah Angie I know I always put on my
freakin put in my fist and I smell the
elbow
has the has the finger smell technique
ever steered you wrong
not till this day has it ever guided you
away from a lady yes Wow then you have
to go back to the hospitality room
that's when you go back for seconds and
find somebody else hey you didn't
complete your first meal